sarajevo entre la calma y la guerra
fantasmagórica
uno puede imaginarse que mañana alguien
lo bombardeara
se la guarda de after que la consola
iglesia
fue un escándalo fue un asedio casi
medieval gente muriendo todo eso a una
hora y media de pared hace alusión al
planteo del gallego si había disparos
había disparos si no pasabas no pasabas
alguna vía cubría juguete legal
pero más se confía merece ley en mitla
pesos ni pedráz no sólo la puja plegada
pueblo king de palop y folk al equipo de
stuart se podría decir que fuimos
ingenuos pensamos que íbamos a parar
todo eso creado en 1945 la república
federal popular de yugoslavia estaba
unida por la voluntad de un hombre el
general tito tras su muerte en 1980 los
nacionalistas se despertaron la caída de
la unión soviética aceleró su toma del
poder en 1991 eslovenia y luego croacia
declararon su independencia
era como un castillo de cartas que
empezó a caerse de
yugoslavia se desintegró en pocos meses
ante la mirada incrédula de la delación
desde las elecciones ya sentíamos que
las cosas no iban bien
desde eslovenia croacia
pero no pensábamos que llegaría hasta
sarajevo
el 6 de abril de 1992 en sarajevo se
realizó una marcha que reunió a miles de
personas croatas bosnios serbios todos
pedían la paz y había docenas y docenas
de buses que traían gente de toda bosnia
y organizamos una gran marcha por la paz
el resultado fue la primera víctima la
regenta
desde el techo del holiday inn los
nacionalistas serbios le dispararon a la
multitud
si era el pánico absoluto
la gente corría de un lado a otro
queridos era un caos caos caos
justo después de los primeros bombardeos
ahí ahí empezaron a disparar en todas
las direcciones
no era solo bombardear y matar gente
para esa gente se trataba del placer de
destruir una civilización de
civilización los serbios que se habían
instalado desde hacía meses en las
colinas que dominan la ciudad comparte
avanzará gevo sin descanso
sarajevo se asienta sobre una depresión
tienen unos 6000 metros de largo y 2.000
metros de ancho y había 250 mil 280 mil
recuerdo que había 280 mil personas que
estaban asediadas
la ciudad era defendida y los serbios no
iban a intentar tomarla entrar o hacer
así que bombardeaban disparaban y
trataban de poner algo de presión sobre
los bosnios para que finalmente se
rindieran
después del primer verano la situación
se estabilizó los bombardeos se hicieron
menos frecuentes primero cortaron el
teléfono
no era grave luego cortaron la
electricidad
incluso aprendimos a hacer velas no
había agua aprendimos a hacer todo con 5
litros de agua a veces menos
todos los árboles de la ciudad acabaron
utilizándose como leña y también los
libros escolares todo eso se utilizó
como leña porque los inviernos podrían
ser bastante duros en julio de 1992 la
onu creó un puente aéreo para llevar
ayuda humanitaria los cascos azules
regularmente objetivos de los serbios
también pagaron un alto precio 200 de
ellos fueron asesinados en la ex
yugoslavia y entre ellos 84 soldados
franceses bajo la bandera de la onu
pasaron tres años al ritmo de bombardeos
y disparos de francotiradores
cada salida podía significar la muerte
lo cual hasta el bombardeo del mercado
de markale el 5 de febrero de 1994 que
el horror de la situación se hizo
insostenible para la comunidad
internacional
68 muertos cientos de heridos
estuve en el lugar unos minutos después
y era realmente una masacre una masacre
especialmente porque se trataba de
mujeres y niños no eran combatientes era
asesinato puro y duro era un crimen de
guerra no hay otras palabras
a menudo no puedo creer que haya
sucedido así pienso que fue un mal sueño
algo así pero esa es la realidad hay que
vivir con eso
aunque la presión internacional
aumentaba sobre los serbios no era
suficiente para levantar el asedio se
necesitaría otro año tras la masacre de
srebrenica en el verano de 1995 y las
acusaciones de limpieza étnica de los
serbios sobre los musulmanes los cascos
azules recibieron finalmente la orden de
liberar sarajevo por la fuerza
esta vez estábamos listos para atacar y
finalmente atacamos una campaña de
bombardeo que duró 10 días terminamos
esta guerra en 10 días el 29 de enero de
1996 después de tres años ocho meses y
nueve días el sitio de sarajevo se
levantó finalmente dejando atrás ruinas
tumbas y muchas lágrimas